okay hello everyone this is Michael wos
here from orderflows
docomo trade analysis for Monday May 1st
2017 uh first a brief disclaimer uh this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results again the reason for the
disclaimer is because trading is not a
get-rich quick scheme uh trading you
know if you apply yourself can provide a
source of income to live on uh you know
many Traders live off the results of
their trading I'm not saying everybody
will have the same results as me or as
more successful Traders but you know
what if you work hard at it you can
succeed um you know just like any uh any
sort of any sort of skill you know it's
a skill set that you can take with you
whether
you trade bonds whether you trade beans
whether you trade sugar you know it's a
skill set that you could have with you
for the rest of your life you know once
you learn something no one could take it
away they could throw you in jail you
know you could get uh um Awards you can
win the Heisman Trophy and you know they
find out you've been doping they'll
they'll take the trophy away from you
but if you have a skill set you know
training it will be with you for life
and the tools that are used in this
presentation are the orderflows Trader
and the Delta scalper you know I promise
to talk a little bit more about the
Delta scalper because you know a lot of
people have been showing interest in it
and it it's a great uh it's a great
little tool for uh trading with
orderflow now you know let's just uh
jump into it real quick this is the euro
currency chart um let's go back to
around 8:00 in the morning 7 in the
morning here you can see Delta scalper
gives a sell here at the high of the day
you got a ratio .222 now a lot of people
have been uh commenting you know explain
more about the ratios basically you know
ratios do two things one they read the
order flow um I used to do these
calculations in my head and you know I
created the orderflows trader software
to plot the ratio on the chart so I
didn't have to do the calculation I can
concentrate on other things in the
Market at the time that's happening and
they what they indicate
is price rejection or Price defense now
there's two types of ratios there's a
ratio bound High there's a ratio bound
low a setting uh just really quick
under might just talk about it here
really quick if you go to the
settings you pull it up slow here ninja
Trader sucks at sometimes it's a little
bit slow whoops and it just
disappeared hope it didn't kill all my
charts but um and did Kill My
Chart here you go setting
or close
Trader you see right here ratio bounds
high above 28 it's a ratio ratio bonds
low below
7699 again you know anything above 28 or
below 699 to zero it's not going to be
negative is going to give you a uh a
ratio a blue number that you like it'll
be on top of a a red bar it'll be on the
top on a green bar it'll be on the
bottom and again what they indicate you
ratio balance High indicates price
rejection ratio bounds low indicates
price defense in this case you're at
your high of the day and there's a signs
of price defense
here and you got the Delta scalper
kicking off telling you in it's reading
the Delta
here and it's telling you hey you know
what you know it's shifting from a
demand driven Market on the way up to a
supply driven
market and you see how we sell off from
this high right down here you get the
price uh Delta scalper again giving you
a buy here and you Rally from this level
you know you you came from your high
down you know what was your high up here
10947 and a half but realistically you
be getting in around 44 45 you know
trades down to 32 and what you do you
rally you go back up make a new high
price rejector sorry price Delta scalper
um giv a sell here as well you know
right off the
high and what do you do you know this is
around the 44 area and look it just
Falls over boom boom boom boom boom get
another sell here with the Delta scalper
and again you trade lower um you know
late in the day a few more indicators in
there uh with the Delta scoper giving
you cells so you know if if you only had
one thing you know if you're reading the
order flow will be a one way you know
the Delta scalper is a great tool um you
know there'll be a link on on the
description if you're more interested in
it or if you're interested in purchasing
it runs on a normal bar chart as well um
you know I had stopped selling it
because you know I don't want people
thinking oh you know Mike you're only
about selling indicators you know not
about teaching and you know honestly i'
I've taken down the link I haven't put
it up it hasn't been up for six months I
stopped selling it last year um but I
get a lot of people still buying it um
you know I I haven't hidden the link but
it's it's just sort of you know out
there I got no nor other the links on my
website to it um just some previous
videos but a lot of people are still
interested in it and I'm sort of
Reviving it um you know for for people
that are interested in it you can you
can still purchase it and the cool thing
is is it runs on a normal bar chart so
if you're just using a normal bar chart
not even using an order close chart it
will work on it okay so the next Market
we'll look at is crude oil and again
with the Delta scalper it wasn't that
many signals here but you come into a
new low here at 10:00 boom you get the
Delta scalper giv a buy right off this
low now the only thing I don't like
about this signal is you know if I'm
buying it I like the bar to be green
comes right back up in the next bar
which is encouraging I don't like the
fact that this bar is red but you know
it comes back into the next bar and is
green okay I'm I'm I'm interested again
but again you know I don't like taking
Buys in bars that are red and you is
this the greatest signal no it just sort
of goes sideways sideways makes a new
low this bar here at 12:00 where you got
the Delta scalper given a signal is is a
bit clearer it's a green bar it's an up
bar this is what you want you know this
one it's a red bar that's not really
what you want you know wait for the next
bar okay you get a little bit of
confirmation there but really what you
want is the bar with the signal to be um
in the direction that you expect the
market to go in this case it's green and
you can see you know this is what time
is at
12:07 very little heat that you took it
came right back down towards you know
this um 64 area and you know rallied all
the way up to you know the mid 80s so
you know that that was a nice a nice
trade there in the crude oil so you saw
crude oil you
saw Euro currency those are both eight
range charts you know I'm not picking
one you know on a one minute chart
because it looks good on today on there
or you know another chart a 10 range
chart cuz it looks good on there these
are charts I use every day eight range
crude oil eight range and Euro
currency okay so the next chart be beans
it's a four range chart I use four range
in the beans you know four range is
gives you five five ticks it's um you
know four range is 1 C well four ticks
is 1 cent so it's just over 1 cent move
now okay we going into these highs this
is what you want to see as you're taking
out highs you want to be seeing
aggressive buying coming in you want to
see buying imbalances and you get
stacked buying IM balance here stack
buying imbalance there all of a sudden
boom we hit this high now this is the
Delta surge you could download the Delta
surge on the website for free and it's
coming off the high you're seeing
selling come in here whereas before this
was a demand driven Market buying buying
buying for a market to sell off it's
going to be driven by Supply people are
going to be coming in selling you see
the Delta surge uh Delta surge right
here imbalances sellers are taking over
there's very little buying Happening
Now imbalance imbalance imbalance
imbalance imbalance imbalance all
negative deltas and you sell off down to
you know the 967 and a half area you
start rallying back up you hit the high
again come off hit the high again make
new highs now this is the beauty of the
Delta search you hit the high here and
it's picking up what's happening in the
Delta you got the Delta Sur uh Delta
scal we kicking off right here that's
this fuchsia
color you sell off when be trade back up
towards this high price rejection with
the ratio you see
34.75 and you sell off coin to the close
for the
day so again you a move from you know
973 down below uh 970
960 I will call it 971 it's not the
greatest move it's a move you could have
participated in it very little heat you
know maybe went one or two ticks three
ticks against you with that but you know
it was a nice a nice trade okay lastly
this is the EM many 10 range chart and
it was very quiet this morning um you
know these bars took about two hours to
form this high was made uh just you know
this bar closed right around the cash
open Delta scalper gives a sell you got
a Divergence on the 10 range chart you
trade from 85 down to uh
81 81 and a half 82 so that's a nice
trade there come back up in price
rejector got the uh Delta scalper given
another sell here again right off this
high this this black one here is the
uh the volto U-turn actually but um
again you got the sell here did it sell
off yeah it did but then it rallied
right back up you know so again you know
this this this trade failed you know I
showed you a lot of Trades that work
sometimes it doesn't sometimes it fails
and it get stopped out um again this is
the Del this is the volto uh U-turn up
here at this high of the day just as you
had it here you get some nice sell-offs
with this Volos U-turn um you go to the
website you can learn more about it but
it's a beautiful you know it's great at
picking uh turning points in the market
so imagine you're selling it up here you
know coming into the night session we we
opened up around uh what was that 86 86
and2 you're getting short around the uh
you know 88 and a half 89
area uh oh you know I didn't talk about
the bonds this
morning okay give me a second
here okay okay um Delta scalper again um
8:30 right on the low of the day Delta
scalper given a Buy in the bonds R you
taking any heat at all this is the
U-turn here but you know you're catching
a move from uh you know the 18 area
below 20 you know all the way up into
you know close to the 30s so so even if
you're getting in at 20 you know you're
getting you good eight ticks out of this
trade pretty quick pretty quick and then
boom you get the swing High Delta the
scalper giving you a sell even gives you
a sell ahead of this uh stack buying
imbalance you imagine you can get in
here right before it falls over you You'
think trading is the greatest thing in
the world you get short and boom big
selling IM balance all zeros or 0 to
08 from you know the 28 area all the way
down
to you know below 12 new lows new lows
new lows new lows new lows down here um
you know you'd be looking you think
trading you honestly you'd see that you
think hey trading is the greatest thing
in the world you get short at 28 where's
it where does it move go to goes down to
you know one full point lower um you
know I I don't want you thinking that
every trade is going to be like that you
know not at all don't don't think that
cuz um you know when it doesn't work out
you'll ah you know Mike he's only he's a
scammer um not every trade is is a full
point um you know then then there are
people out there that are like that so
anyway um you know again this is the
Volus urn U-turn U-turn here so sell Buy
Buy um you another cell here um at this
point honestly you just had this monster
move a full basis point and now you're
just going sideways here U I'm not
surprised by that price activity okay uh
lastly I'll look at the five years um
really quick it's probably going to be
kind of similar to the bonds but we'll
check it
out
okay you know 8 o00 price reject uh
Delta scalper boom it sells off from the
12 area down to you know the 9 area 9
and a half again Delta scalper a lot of
sells here boom one here one here before
it starts its monster move down again
you know if if you're in this you got
the Delta scalper here boom you get some
confirming signals you got point of
control at the top of this bar you've
got a ratio bounds low indicating
stopping volume you can see it here
eight you know 1,000 on the offer here
again another bar with a ratio bonds low
indicating stopping volume 500 up here
300 and you know so you know that
there's there's Supply up here you know
there's people up here got
offers and they're putting their foot on
the market saying you know what Market
you're not going any higher and what
does it do it sells off from you know
this 12 Area 11 area straight down you
know this is a this is a tremendous move
in the five years from 12 all the way
down to 6 and a half um you know that
that's a beautiful move here you get the
Delta scalper again giving you a cell
signal boom you get a nice little move
lower um you know before closing at the
day right around where the the Delta
scoper gave you the signal this is the
U-turn again here it's a nice little uh
a nice little uh signal it's nice little
indicator so again you know that's just
two simple tools you know it's the order
flows Trader the Delta scalper Delta
scalper works on a normal bar chart so
say you don't want to sit here and
analyze what's going on you know in the
order flow like like I was talking here
um you know yeah you've got you know
point of control at the top you got a
ratio a ratio you know these are
confirming signs that you like to see
you know when you're getting short you
know that's the beauty of orderflow
orderflow is a tool right but when you
use it with your analysis if you could
learn to read the market that's what
trading is about is learning to read the
market it's not learning to sell when um
you know a 40 period moving average
costes a 20 moving average that's not
trading you know that's like having a
checklist if you want to have a
checklist you know okay we cross this
moving average we cross this moving
average it's time to get short go work
at McDonald's you know Starbucks make
$10 $15 an hour whatever the minimum
wage is now in some of these countri or
states are trying to keep raising it
that's not trading trading is
understanding what's happening in the
market and reacting to it you know think
like an entrepreneur trading is very
entrepreneurial in a way actually I mean
it's not in the sense where you building
something or building a business you
know it's about reading the market it's
about problem solving um you know people
don't understand that it's you know you
have a problem in front it's like a
puzzle right you're trying to put the
puzzle together it's problem solving you
know the reason why companies like apple
do so well is because you know they find
the problems out there and they solve it
you know when uh Steve Jobs created the
you know honestly Apple was in the
um you know back in you know
before the iPod came out and you know
Steve Jobs you know his Visionary he
solved the problem you know hey I like
carrying music you know on my hip you
know with the Walkman but you know you
can carry so much music there you know
on a cassette and you know obviously you
can't carry a record player and and you
can't carry your whole collection of
cassette tapes and all that with you so
he solved the problem he came out with
the iPod all right and that that solved
the problem that made life you know
things a lot easier for you and you know
trading is the same way it's about
solving the problem that's presented to
you and by learning to read the market
and understand what's happening in the
market you can solve the problem of the
market in a sense you know again you're
getting signals up here price rejection
this ratio 474 price defense with this
ratio 22 it's a ratio balance high it's
a ratio balance low I mean it doesn't
get any freaking clearer here
honestly you know and you got the the
Delta scoper which reads the Delta I
could read this myself but not everyone
can you know not everyone's familiar
with order flows and that's fine you
know that's why I create these
indicators to help people understand
what's happening in the market um
without knowing all the little
intricacies of reading the Delta and you
know looking at the ratios you know
trying to calculate this in your head is
their price acceptance is their price
rejection that's what all these tools
these are tools to help you as a Trader
um you know become a better Trader you
know you the best Carpenter in the world
needs his tools and the software is your
tool all right all these little things
are your tools to help you understand
what's happening in the market better
and again it's not based on oh this
moving average cross here or your macd
you know which is also moving average or
your RSI oh we overbought oversold no
it's clear it's telling you what's
traded in the market
and when prices
okay simple simple thing price rejection
what is price rejection when there's no
more buying okay buyers are rejecting
higher prices okay we came up here one
lot traded price rejection where's your
other buyers and when there's no more
buyers in the market the Market's going
to drop down now if you understand that
okay so you come up here you trade one
lot you know testing and see what's up
there there's probably size up there and
so that's why people are rejecting it
price comes off a bit and then hey you
know buyers come right back in they step
right back up aggressive buying balance
1, 575 557 you boom you get up here
again this is the area you had price
rejection now you can see why you had
price rejection because there was big
seller up here a thousand Lots traded up
here okay even went bid here sellers
came in hit that bid boom we dropped
down very little volume here 231 41 662
selling IM balance so you know sellers
are dominating this Market say you're
not convinced yet you know I don't
believe you Mike you know yeah that's
subjective look at the next bar again
again you come down lower Tred ring back
up boom you got sellers stepping up here
you've got price defense this is the
ratio bounds low 64 it's a blue number
and it's below 7 again I showed you the
settings earlier again um indicates
price excuse me I I still got this sore
throat indicates price rejection you can
see point of control right at the top
the heaviest volume in this bar right at
the top just as this bar heaviest volume
right at the top so you know there's a
lot of sellers going on up here even
when it goes bit here there's selling
sell sell sell and the market sells off
you got selling IM balances aggressive
sellers boom boom boom boom and the
market sells off this is you know if if
you fail to see this maybe orderflow is
not for you it's not for everybody I'll
be honest you know order flow is not for
everybody people don't want to take the
time to learn you know they want to
blame other people for their failure
rather than taking time to learn you
know trading is something that could be
taught and you know I've talked about
this before you know I I worked in a
bank JP Morgan for eight years I worked
in another bank Comer's Bank the one of
the biggest German banks before all they
all started going down the a few
years
ago um you know I worked at cargo the
biggest Trading Company in the world you
know I worked at EDF man again one of
the bigger trading companies in the
entire world and you know I would see
new Traders come in they don't want to
put in the effort you know they think oh
you know I graduated top honors at at
this University so what you know some of
the most brilliant Traders on the on the
exchange floor never went to college you
know you would think honestly you think
that they're they're a slob you know
they they got no other skill other than
um you know scalping on the floor but
they're brilliant at it why because they
took the time to learn and I see these
new Traders thinking you know hey I'm
I'm a high flyer I'm a primadonna you
know I graduated my top level you know
sumak Kum La you know I'm brilliant you
know you're not you know the market is a
great way of taking people down a notch
and um you know they they think you know
everything's going to be handed to them
they got to learn how to trade you got
to learn how to read the market if you
don't want to do it then you'll never be
successful and it would kill me because
I know people can do it and the ones
that don't want to you know put in the
time and effort start blaming other
people oh you know uh my mentor here in
the bank you know wasn't very good
didn't teach me the things you know it's
his fault that I'm not a good Trader
well you know what if if it's like that
you know those people don't last you
know three months 6 months they're gone
you know the banks you know you got to
you know some of these firms you got to
start producing um really quick and if
you're not you know you're just um you
know hanging on there are some companies
that you know I I know the guys that own
the company you know they don't like to
fire people they they'll just lower
their wages down down down but you know
it's
a you know I want to say a doggy dog
world but you know what to survive in
this if you want to be successful in
trading and you want
to make money you got to learn how to
trade you know I said it's it's easy
when you're 25 years old you you got
your MBA from you know Chicago univ
Chicago Booth School you know I I I I
would love have loved to gone there you
know just simply because I know when I
get out there's probably a job for
waiting for me that's going to pay me
100 Grand you know a year probably more
now
but that's not really what I wanted to
do in life is work for somebody else you
know and make them money and and yeah
they'll pay me money but you know I I I
wanted to be a Trader ever since I was
you know in my teens and you know you
got to learn you got to take the time to
learn this stuff I mean I I can't put in
any other
other way um you know now we're in this
age where people's attention spans are
so short you know they would want
everything handed to them you know teach
me how to trade in in two days no it
doesn't it doesn't work that way um you
know if if you want to learn you can you
got to apply yourself there's this thing
called um the library and now it's
Google but um you know read whatever you
can you know people I don't have time
I'm busy um you know
you can you have time during the day you
know you're sitting around you know in
the grocery store in the cashier line
surf the Internet you know I've got
videos downloaded on my phone you know I
watch things you know for other topics I
want to learn on you know there's
there's always time you're sitting in
bed you know my wife sits in bed for an
extra two hours she just sits there and
and reads or you know reads stuff and
you know she's she's learning even
though you know kids are asleep next to
her that's her time that she's going to
spend time learning something so you
know when people say oh I got this going
on I got that going on you can
find the time you know being a
successful businessman entrepreneur
trading is entrepreneurial in its sense
you find the time you know you don't
come up with
excuses a lot of people you know they
they they have
excuses excuse me hold
on again you ask yourself do you want to
be successful or not you know if you
want to be you'll you'll make it happen
you know it won't just fall into your
lap so anyway you I digress that was my
rant for the
day so again you have to learn more
about uh trading with the orderflows
trader software or how you can profit
from orderflow visit my website order
flows.com but if you're interested in
the Delta
scalper uh what I do let me
just go back here I'll make this a
little bit shorter you know it's a
little bit smaller bit
big going on to 40 but again I'm going
to put the link
here I don't hate
that um
www.d Deltas scalper if you're
interested in the Delta
scalper again Delta scalper I created a
website I thought I took it down
actually because I wasn't keen on
selling it that much anymore but you
know what why because you know I don't
want people say oh you know Mike you're
just out there to get money and there
are people like that you know um you
know they they they think oh you just
cuz they can't get it to work for
themselves
this is Deltas scaler.com you know and
you can see you how it works on the
normal bar chart yeah you have trades
that lose like this one okay would you
rather are you happy to catch this move
here are you willing to risk this to
catch a move like this yeah you should
be and you know it's 250 it's not a lot
but you know it's worth it it's good
investment so thanks and uh hope to hear
from you bye-bye